[Music]
hey you guys it's finally here halloween
the best day of the whole entire year
and if you don't agree then get the [ __ ]
off my channel seriously no i'm just
kidding uh so yeah so obviously this
week i've been doing my halloween eek
week series i was doing all these extra
movie reviews movies that really like
just screamed halloween to me
and also ones old and new that i hadn't
got around to doing and that were long
overdue
now this one i had to do this one on
actual halloween because this might be
i don't know i don't know if i want to
say this but as far as like family
friendly type movies go this might be
like the most halloweeny of all
halloween movies i'm not talking about
horror movies and stuff like that
because this is definitely not a horror
movie even though it has some dark
elements to it
but this movie it had like kind of a
fascinating production history which
i'll get into in a minute and actually i
didn't even really know about it like
when i first saw it back in the 90s
but this is of course the
family-friendly halloween classic hocus
pocus from 1993.
now interestingly um this is a disney
movie
and because we've done let's see we did
something wicked this way comes which
was from kind of the dark disney era
where they were making very dark
family fare in the 1980s which like i
said at the time didn't do all that well
but then later on got kind of a cult
following we've also talked about uh not
disney but also the movie the jim henson
movie the the witches based on the royal
doll thing which again aimed at children
but super super dark this one has some
aspects of that too it has some dark
elements to it but this one is just a
lot more fun a lot more silly it's not
really supposed to be taken as scary it
doesn't really have that many scary
elements in it although when you kind of
describe what happens in the plot to
somebody that hasn't seen it it does
kind of sound darker than it is but
because the tone of it is so over the
top comedic that it gets away with it so
like i said we're talking dark disney
but it's not
nearly as dark as some of the stuff that
came out
earlier and like i said not dearly not
nearly as dark as the witches from 1990
which was straight up terrifying this
one is just kind of more silly campy
fun um aimed at probably younger
children although honestly let's see
this came out in
1993. and i feel like i saw this in the
theater because this came out right
around well no this came out like before
nightmare before christmas but i was
kind of like seeing a lot of movies in
the theater at this time i might have
seen it like at a second run like in a
dollar theater because i was doing that
a lot too because i was broke dick at
that time but uh so i feel like i did
see this in the theater and even though
it's aimed at younger kids it's still
like fun enough for adults to enjoy as
well and like i said it's one that
always kind of like puts me in the
halloween mood because it's a very very
very halloween movie takes place on
halloween there's trick-or-treating in
it there's a big halloween party ever
you know there's witches and black cats
and it's just it's just really just fun
you know what i mean now i have seen
it's weird because i don't know i i saw
it when it came out and then like i've
seen it a few times subsequently and i'm
always like oh it's like a fun halloween
movie it's not one that i watch every
year i know some people do
but i was aware that
in the past few years specifically as
millennials have gotten older and had
their own children and things like that
um this has really become i would call
it a cult phenomenon uh they've done
like musicals of it they have uh around
halloween at disney world and disneyland
i think they have a hocus pocus themed
show like villain spectacular or
something like that uh spirit halloween
has like a big line of hocus pocus
themed products that you can buy which
are all really cool so i kind of felt
like yeah there's this massive like cult
phenomenon around it although a lot of
people it's interesting because when i
was researching this show
and i was kind of interested because i
knew about
you know the cultural impact that this
movie has had particularly among kids
who grew up in the 90s
i didn't realize there was also kind of
like this other contingent of people
that really really hated it and just
thought it was so like they didn't
really get like why everyone's super
into it because they're like this movie
is just so
over the top and so loud and so annoying
and like not funny and all this other
kind of stuff i kind of fall somewhere
in the middle this is this is a movie
that you have to approach you know it's
halloween you have some kids or you have
it on in the background like at a party
it's kind of just like a feel-good type
of movie it's you know it's it is very
over the top it is very campy look so
the tone of it is just more of kind of
like a silly you know halloween kind of
romp i guess rather than it being
anything
like the witches which is kind of a
little bit more intense or actually a
lot more intense so this one if you go
into it with that
mindset of it just being like a wacky
you know kids movie essentially and this
one is very much aimed at younger kids
even though like i said some of the uh
subject matter's a little bit dark when
you talk about it uh but it is very very
much a kids movie and a lot of the humor
is kid
friendly although when i was re-watching
this i hadn't seen it for several years
when i was re-watching this yesterday i
was surprised how much sexual idiot
would sit there that i guess i did it i
mean i'm sure i caught it like the first
time because i think i was gosh how old
would i have been i was i think i was 21
or 22 when this came out like i said i'm
pretty sure i saw the theater so i would
have understood the sexual references
obviously but it didn't really i didn't
really remember that much about it i
remember the whole thing about the kid
being a virgin and everything see
there's another thing with uh when i was
talking about monster squad where
there's that whole thing about i'm
talking about a five-year-old girl being
a virgin this one you know a little less
problematic but they still are because
it's they're talking about a boy and
he's like a teenager like in high school
but still a little weird that they're
like making fun of him for being a
version of like dude he's like 15 it's
like i know that that's a thing like in
high school like making fun of kids that
you know but it's it's just a little
weird so and it's a little weird to have
like your little sister picking on you
about it too i was just kind of like
okay but uh yeah so
one thing that i did not realize there's
a lot of things i didn't realize about
this movie because like i said i was
just been aware of this movie like ever
since i was in my 20s because it was
just always kind of in the background
and you know a people would show it like
every halloween and i think even now
freeform
which i think is owned by disney i think
it used to be abc family and uh every
october
they show this movie like
pretty much on an endless loop it's
almost kind of like you know how around
christmas story like around christmas
like some channels will show a christmas
story like just over and over they'll
show it for like 24 hours i kind of feel
like that sort of
uh cultural saturation has happened with
hocus pocus so when i went back to
research like you know when this first
came out i was actually quite shocked to
discover that this when this came out in
the theater it was pretty much a total
bomb now
there are probably a lot of factors for
that probably the main factor i feel
like was that disney released it in
july for [ __ ] sake i know why they did
it because nightmare before christmas
was which was also disney was coming out
in october and they didn't want the two
movies to cannibalize one another to
compete with one another so they just
kind of and maybe they didn't have a lot
of faith in hocus pocus uh you know when
they made it so it's just kind of like
they just dumped it like in july
and it obviously didn't do all that well
i think the first week that it premiered
it came in fourth
uh it was after i think some other [ __ ]
had come out that way like in the line
of fire which is that's a great movie
too and a couple other ones and i think
it even came out behind jurassic park
which had already been out for like more
than a month at that point
so you know it and and you can
understand why it's like nobody i mean
if you're not me
nobody wants to go in the middle of
hot ass summer in july and see
a very very halloweeny halloween movie
it just doesn't like i said i would but
apparently most people wouldn't do that
so it made money but it didn't make uh
its production budget back so it was
kind of considered a flop
and it got really
scathingly bad reviews like at the time
uh siskel and ebert most famously they
hated it and they were just kind of like
there's like it's not funny it's just
like over the top and it's just like all
this mugging and screeching and you know
and bette midler is just like wasted in
it and so like the only good part about
it is like her musical number in the
middle and so they just it got like
ravaged it got some good reviews too but
most of them were pretty negative so you
know so there was that so i didn't
realize that this movie which now seems
so beloved by generations of people
was kind of like really not much of a
thing when it came out but what ended up
happening over the years
was that
even though it didn't do that well at
the theater now when october rolled
around i'm not sure if october 93 or the
following october because disney owned
you know the family channel you know abc
family or whatever it was called back
then they decided to they're like well
you know we have this halloween movie
laying around and it didn't do very well
in the theater but we have tv and we can
put it on for free so why not and they
have this thing that they would do every
year called like uh 13 days of halloween
and they started putting hocus pocus in
the rotation uh for their halloween
season like they had a bunch of other
movies too i think they'd show
beetlejuice and some other things as
well
but they started to notice that whenever
hocus pocus was on around the halloween
season the ratings would spike so at
that point they're like maybe we have
some kind of sleeper hit on our hands
here so they started showing it more and
more and then when they released it on
uh dvd and then again on blu-ray they
noticed that during october sales of
that would go like through the roof like
so it would be on tv all the time and it
would be like when it came out on dvd
and blu-ray and i think it came out on
vhs first and that was like a big hit
too so they started to notice that right
around october which is when they should
have released it in the first place
might have been a whole different uh
situation but they started to notice
right around october sales of this would
spike up and subsequently kids who grew
up in the 90s uh you know millennials
things like that they started they saw
this a lot as a kid and it would always
be on around halloween so there came to
be this kind of like real nostalgia
factor associated with it i think kind
of like the same way that
kids of my era
um we always grow up watching like you
know it's a great pumpkin charlie brown
and you know all those kind of like
halloween specials i was going to say
the worst witch but i don't
i don't know how much of a beloved
cultural icon that is i think it's
mostly like forgotten tim curry was in
it by the way if you've never seen it's
awful but
it's also kind of awesome isn't diana
rigg in it i want to say diana rigg is
in it i was like reading something about
i know this is a little bit off topic
but i was reading something about the
worst witch somebody made a comment
about it and they basically said and so
this i didn't make this up i'm
paraphrasing from some clever person on
the internet that was commenting they
basically said the worst witch is like
if the first harry potter movie was made
by crazy people and also only spent 87
on it it was like and i'm like accurate
yeah that's pretty accurate i haven't
seen it a long time but i remember i
mean the special effects are just like
it's i don't know it's just like funny
but like i said we'd always kind of like
watch the same kind of stuff around
halloween and you know hocus pocus
became that for 90s kids and as they
gotta grow up and had their own kids you
know they would show it to their kids so
it almost kind of became like a
halloween tradition like i said so much
so that the shit's like [ __ ]
saturated and i just found out like from
the wikipedia page that literally like a
week ago like october 18th
they started
production they started shooting
the sequel for this so
obviously there was demand out there
like i said there's a whole disney show
there's a whole it's a whole thing now
which is crazy and it's just crazy to
think that when it first came out
everybody was like meh you know what i
mean um like i said i kind of fall
somewhere in the middle of this it's
like it's a really fun movie to watch
for halloween but you really kind of
have to be in the mood for it because it
is very over the top and it's very campy
and there is a lot of screaming and
stuff like that and a lot of like kind
of dumb humor but
if you're in the mood for that then it
can be just with the doctor and like i
said it is very very halloweeny it has a
very halloween tone to it and it's just
like really really fun so if you've
never seen this movie somehow which i
know some people haven't um basically
you have at the beginning there's like a
um you know a thing from back in like
the 1600s in salem massachusetts
obviously and there's these three
witches the sanderson sisters and they
are played by bette midler who plays the
main one she's winifred or winnie and
then you got sarah jessica parker she
plays the dumb one the dumb bimbo named
sarah and then you have uh kathy jimmy
playing uh mary who's kind of like she's
the one that sniffs out the kids and
she's also kind of dumb but like the the
two background witches are are dumb and
then like one of the main running gags
is that bette midler is always kind of
like brow beating them because they're
so stupid but you know so it's almost
kind of like a three stooges i would
even get yeah it is it is very much like
three stitches i mean they never go
knuckle yuck or anything and like poke
anybody in the eyes but it's almost to
that level so like i said if you're not
into the three stooges you might not dig
this movie because it does definitely
have that kind of like slap sticky kind
of comedy to it
so these three witches they basically
like i said this it's not as dark as
some other disney movies that came out
in the 80s but it's still kind of dark
because it does start with these three
witches straight up kidnapping a little
nine-year-old girl named emily and like
taking her into the hut
and they feed her this potion that has
like dead man's toes in it and stuff and
then they feed it to her and then they
suck out her life force so they straight
up like kill a nine-year-old girl they
don't like show it show it but they do
show like them sucking her souls out
because that makes them like younger so
then her brother
uh her older brother thackery banks
comes in and tries to save the little
girl but is unsuccessful and the witches
uh turn him into a black cat who will
live forever uh because that's their
curse like not only is he cursed to live
as a cat which actually would be kind of
awesome if you ask me but
but he has to live forever because he
has to live with the guilt of not being
able to save his sister
so then the townsfolk all come with the
pitchforks and whatnot and they straight
up hang the three witches uh so again
child murder and
and witches hanging uh in the first five
minutes of a disney kids movie but like
i said the tone of it is just kind of so
silly and over the top that it almost
doesn't register
like i guess how dark it is because i'm
just like okay kid's dead whatever
moving on but uh so yeah so then we jump
ahead to present day 300 years later and
we're still in salem massachusetts we
have this angsty teen named max
and he's just moved to salem from la and
he's really not happy about it and uh is
just constantly coveting
and uh so he has an adorable younger
sister uh played by thora burch who is
actually other than bette midler i think
thora burch is like the best part of
this she's like cute as a button because
i kind of feel like and i'm not [ __ ]
on the movie too much but i kind of feel
like the two main teenagers you know at
the center of the action are they're not
bad or anything like that they're just
very bland but i do kind of feel like
the little sister has like is has like a
sparkly personality and she has like
some of the funniest lines in the [ __ ]
so you know so i'm glad they kind of put
her in there to kind of spice the [ __ ]
up a little bit uh it's halloween is
approaching and he's getting made fun of
at school he's like he's from la and
everybody's kind of making fun of that
and he just really doesn't like this new
salem situation and he really does not
like halloween i don't understand that
at all because everybody likes halloween
come on but he's like really really
grumpy about it
and so he gets picked on by bullies like
the bullies steal his shoes for some
reason which actually was that that was
the thing right like in the 90s i kind
of feel like people like oh the gang
bangers are going to shoot you and take
your nikes because the nikes are 100 or
whatever so i kind of feel like maybe
and probably also nike paid for product
placement in this because they
definitely were nikes um there was
there's a couple other like product
placement in here too maybe clark bar
which i'll get to in a minute but if i
remember
but yeah somebody did like specifically
mention clark bars i'm like wow man do
they still make those maybe they did in
the 90s i guess i don't know if they
still make them or not i don't even
remember what the [ __ ]
clark bar is what's in those is it
caramel i don't know i don't remember
anyway in in class it's halloween is
coming up and the teacher is telling as
she presumably does every year she's
telling the high school kids like the
legend of the sanderson sisters and uh
you know and how they're supposed to
like they they always want to like kill
all the children of salem and like take
all their souls so they can remain young
and beautiful forever and all this other
stuff and max is of course like [ __ ]
this is so lame blah blah blah so
there's that whole thing however there
is a girl in his class who he's kind of
crushing on and uh even though it's so
funny i'm sure these two actors are
probably like the same age when this
movie was made but it's always kind of
like i guess because you know younger
boys like they don't
age as quickly as girls so the girl like
looks probably like three or four years
older than him even though i'm sure he's
not so it's like it's always a little
weird when i see
uh when i see movies like this it's i i
have to say i call it the karate kid
syndrome because even though i'm pretty
sure ralph macchio and um what's her
name that was in that i don't know i
think they were closer in age than they
looked but he looked way way younger
than her and it always like made me
really uncomfortable and uh because i
was like dude it's like she didn't look
old enough to be his mom but almost this
isn't quite that egregious but he
definitely does look a few years younger
than her even though maybe he wasn't
so uh so they're kind of crushing and
they hang out
and uh but he kind of gets humiliated by
the bullies and everything and then uh
you know if life wasn't lame enough as
if he wasn't put upon enough he also has
to take his little sister out
trick-or-treating because their parents
are going to a halloween party so of
course he just like
gets all angsty pants about that and
gets picked on by bullies again and he
just thinks like oh my god this is my
life is the worst blah blah
so like i said he's a real kind of like
whiny so while he's out they sort of
straight up wander into a house
belonging to well they don't know this
but he wanders into this house that
belongs to his crush
and uh they're having a big party and i
guess it's like an open house type of
situation so he walks in there and um
somebody says i guess because the little
sister is dressed up like a witch and
the the girlfriend what the [ __ ] is her
name girlfriend's name is allison it
took me like for some reason it took me
like forever to [ __ ] find that but
yeah so and the little girl's name is
danny i don't know if i mentioned that
before so that he wanted so they want
her in allison's house and allison uh is
kind of like oh yeah i'm like really
into witches too because danny is
dressed up like a witch she's like
matter of fact um i think she says my
mom used to like run the sanderson
sisters museum and because their house
is totally still there and so max is
like well let's go check it out because
you know this party is boring and
whatever it's like it's like allison's
parents party and she's just like you
know i'm not down for it
so they go to
uh the museum which used to be the
sanderson's house and there's a legend
that on halloween night if somebody
lights this black flame candle but it
has to be a virgin though they don't
specify whether it's a boy or a girl
virgin which that's very nice because
the monster squad had to be a girl
virgin this one doesn't matter it's an
equal opportunity virgin candle so
whoever lights the candle will bring the
witches back so of course even though uh
alison and danny are like yeah no let's
not do that max decides for whatever
reason no i'm gonna do it anyway you
guys are being chicken [ __ ] so he lights
it and of course uh the witches come
back
now also into this mix uh if you
remember
thackery binks the kid whose sister got
killed like 300 years ago he got turned
into a black cat
and uh he was also immortal so he's
still around too so apparently how he
spent his immortality
is hanging around the sanderson house
trying to keep people from coming in
there and lighting the candle however he
wasn't uh able to prevent
idiot max from lighting the candle so
obviously the witches come back now the
caveat being that the witches are only
back for halloween night and then when
like when it's morning they'll turn to
dust unless they suck out a bunch of
children's souls i don't know if they
have to do i guess they just have to do
at least one and that'll put like more
gas in their tank and then they can just
get all the because they are actually
trying to
essentially kill all the children in
salem so like i said it's a little dark
it's a lot of child murder potential
child murder going on in this uh you
know in child peril but as i said
because it's so over the top it doesn't
really read as all that dark so
basically the rest of the movie is them
trying to them and binks the cat who
also talks although
he doesn't start talking until
later because you would think that if he
was trying to like warn people about
the sisters like hey don't light that
candle cause for real the witches will
come back no i'm serious you'd think
that he would be able to talk but he
doesn't talk prior to that so maybe
somebody had to light the candle for him
to be able to talk that's not really
made clear and maybe i'm thinking about
it too much but yeah so but he does talk
and uh so he like helps them out
with all the lore and tells them like
what to do and everything oh and there's
also
winnie's uh you know bette midler's
spell book which is magical and has a
moving eye on the front of it which is
super cool i really i actually really
like that
that effect she needs that to cause the
kids steal it because of course they do
and then she needs it back uh to make
the potion that will the soul sucking
potion like she needs to put in she
because it's been 300 years since she
made it like give her a break it's given
it's been 300 years since she made it
last time and she can't remember exactly
how to make it so she needs the book now
the book has like a homing spell on it
but there's ways kind of around that so
basically the rest of the movie is just
the kids trying to evade the witches the
witches doing there's like some little
slapstick gags about
them uh not knowing what a paved road is
or not knowing what a bus is
but all in all uh they seem to really
kind of like catch on to the 20th
century pretty quickly so you know good
on them also there's some kind of funny
[ __ ] where because they can walk around
freely because it's halloween so
everybody just thinks they're they're in
costume right
and uh so they're at this one house and
they leave their magical brooms outside
and these little girls who are who are
dressed like the sanderson sisters like
straight up steal them because i guess
their parents never told them it's like
hey those aren't yours but they were
just kind of like hey cool brooms
i guess guess somebody just left them
here for us so they took them and uh so
so it ends up that the actual sanderson
sisters have to like go back to the
house which had subsequently been turned
into a museum and they have to get like
like winnie gets a broom even though
it's like a more modern broom uh i think
sarah gets a mop and then of course uh
poor mary has to ride on a vacuum
cleaner so they get a couple like uh
gags out of that as well them flying
around and like i said taking a bus and
whatnot and uh so there's a point in
halfway through where
i think like the kids think they lure
the witches to the school like the high
school and for whatever reason the high
school has
like a room like a kiln i guess it's a
kiln like for the art thing or a boiler
i don't know what it is but it's like a
room and they put slate you can like
turn fire on
and they didn't they don't even lock the
school i guess back in the 90s maybe
they didn't i don't know but so they
they lure the witches in there and they
put them in and then they think that
they burn them alive so again which is
burning alive that's nice in a kid's
movie but it doesn't work although i was
not clear on why it didn't work
like because it seemed like it was
working because they were all in there
and they were burning and they were
screaming and stuff and then like the
green [ __ ] comes out of the uh you know
the chimney or whatever and but then the
the the green stuff like reverses and
goes back in and they're just like oh
never mind we're fine and they like
weren't even singed or anything so but i
guess because it was halloween night
there was like a magical spell on them
sort of and like they couldn't die until
dawn came or whatever like i said again
i'm thinking about it too much but uh so
for a long time the kids
think that the witches are dead so they
still have the book and then they think
to themselves well maybe we should try
and reverse the spell on banks the cat
because and turn them back into a boy
because he'd probably appreciate that
but then when they open the book up the
book has like a beacon
and like it shines all over the place so
of course like the witches see it and
they go chasing after him also a really
happy addition to this and i you know i
really like this uh this edition in the
movie is
i guess like back in the old days bette
midler's character winnie
had been knocking boots with this uh guy
named billy butcherson butcherson
and she and then he started like fooling
around with sarah
sarah jessica parker's character the hot
one
and uh so winnie straight up poisoned
him so he's dead but now she can go to
the cemetery and like bring him back as
a zombie essentially because the witches
can't go
they can't walk around in the cemetery
because it's hallowed grounds right so
she has to kind of like get one of her
minions come up out of the grave
although billy doesn't really like her
all that much obviously because uh she
poisoned him and he's and she's always
like bossing him around that uh billy
billy butcherson is played by the great
doug jones which i didn't realize if you
don't know doug jones i mean he was in
all he was in pan's labyrinth uh he
played the fawn and he played the pale
man he was in hellboy he played a uh
abe's whatever abe sapien yeah he plays
that he's usually i mean he's played
himself like you know as himself but
he's usually real good because he's real
tall and thin and he's a mime and you
know a contortionist so he usually plays
like a lot of those kind of like
otherworldly creatures and stuff like
that and he's really great at it but
yeah he plays billy butcherson in this
and uh so there's some funny shenanigans
with billy having like his uh mouth
stitched clothes and like he gets his
head knocked off a couple of times but i
really really like the design of his
outfit so he um he kind of helps the
witches at first but then he decides
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and like starts helping
the kids because he's sick of like when
he you know yelling at him all the time
and like bossing him around like i said
and she did poison him to be fair so
he's not real inclined to be a
magnanimous horner i suppose but yeah so
so that's kind of how it goes there's
like a musical number in there which is
actually great and they they reproduce
this a lot when they do like stage i
gotta say too that i feel like this
movie
has a big following in uh like the drag
community they've they've done like a
lot of drag versions of this usually
like around halloween um if you if you
have like a drag troop or you know drag
show in your town uh most of them will
do a hocus pocus uh you know parody
because that's kind of like you know
because i know bette midler is like a
massively gay icon and everything so i
do kind of feel like that's where she
got some of her performance for this
because you can tell even though they're
the witches
are
totally over the top and it's just so so
silly and just like i said it's almost
like three stooges kind of stuff going
on
but you can tell that the three of them
particularly bette midler are having the
[ __ ] time of their lives they look
like they're just having a blast just
playing these ridiculous like silly
witch characters and they're just like
they play off each other and they're
always like knocking each other around
and like yelling at each other and
calling each other's names and stuff
like that and it's just like so so funny
and i think bette midler even said later
on that this was actually one of her
favorite roles because she just loved
just the over-the-top villainy and just
being able to just be so [ __ ] just be
so campy and ridiculous and you can just
tell she's having a great time with it i
will say that
had this movie not leaned full on into
particularly the witch characters had
this movie not leaned full on into campy
ridiculousness i think it would have
kind of been forgotten there's other
good elements to it like i really like
you know the talking cat thing you know
and i really like doug jones character
he's not in it a lot but you know that's
a really good look and that's a really
good character i really like the
halloween vibe of it but
i kind of feel like the heart of this is
those three witches and their
interactions with one another and like i
said if it wasn't so over the top
i don't know if this would have gotten
the cult following that it got because
this is one of those movies and i've
seen this said too that it's not a good
movie if you want to call like it's not
an objectively
good movie like it you know the plot's
kind of thin and you know the some of
the like the main character kids are
kind of bland other than the little girl
she's awesome but because the witches
are just so
they just went all the way with it and
they're just like yeah we're just gonna
chew up all the scenery and spit it out
um i think that really like elevates it
because
you can tell they're having a really
good time and that kind of makes you
have a good time too even though like i
said you have to be in the mood for it
because it is very screamy
you know what i mean i didn't real i had
forgotten like how screamy this movie
was how much yelling there is going on
in this movie which normally i don't
like but it was fun you know what i mean
so but there's also that great musical
number in the middle where uh where
bette midler like the the witches go to
the halloween party where you know max
and danny's parents are and uh they kind
of take over the stage because you know
max goes there and tries to warn
everybody hey you know go home and get
your kids because the witches are out
and they're like gonna kill all the
children but of course nobody believes
him and uh so then they instead of like
the witches hiding they'd just be like
yeah here we are and they come up on the
stage and start singing that i put a
spell on you kind of thing and they kind
of put a spell on everybody at the party
to just like dance all night so also
conveniently it puts like all the
parents who are all at this party in
salem uh out of commission like for the
run of the movie so the kids pretty much
have to like figure [ __ ] out for
themselves but uh but yeah so i forgot
to mention too another thing that i
didn't realize when i first went to see
this movie was that it was actually
co-written by
mick garris who obviously horror fans
will know he's done a [ __ ] ton of uh
directed a [ __ ] ton of stephen king
adaptations uh particularly sleepwalkers
among others and uh he was also uh the
guy behind the masters of horror series
from showtime uh you know so massive
like horror icon uh so the fact that he
co-wrote this one i think what
originally ended up happening was the
original
uh script for this and this kind of
happens a lot i guess the original
scripture this was actually much darker
it was kind of about the same thing
about like three hanged witches when
they come back to the modern era and
they're trying to like get all the kids
to suck their souls out or whatever but
it was supposed to be much darker and
they actually first approached amblin
entertainment which is steven
spielberg's thing and uh steven
spielberg uh i guess he didn't really
want to do it because i disney had
optioned it and he was just like yeah
you know disney i don't want to do
anything with disney because they were
kind of like rivals at the time
so i guess that's how that happened so
when disney took the project over they
softened it they basically said because
i think initially this was supposed to
be
like a kid's horror movie you know not
horror horror but it was supposed to be
like a kid friendly horror movie for
halloween um but when disney took it
over and read through it they're like
yeah this is way too dark so they
basically just turned into straight up
comedy so don't go into this like
thinking that it's a kid's horror movie
because it's not it's not scary um you
know like i said it has a zombie in it
it has child murder in it but the tone
of it is so obviously comedic
that
it's not i don't think any child
anywhere unless they were really really
like delicate would be scared by this at
all it's just it's mostly just a fun
over-the-top
funny kind of you know what i mean which
was this goofball like kid kind of humor
but i can definitely see why uh a cult
kind of grew up around this but like i
said it almost i didn't realize until i
went and like read a bunch of different
reviews and stuff how kind of love it or
hate it this movie is because i always
kind of felt like i said i don't know if
i say that i love it but
whenever halloween comes around i always
kind of feel like oh you know maybe
we'll maybe watch hocus pocus it's you
know it just kind of like puts you in
the mood uh but like i said you kind of
have it's very silly so you kind of have
to be
down for that um but i can see how kids
that grew up in the 90s this would be
their kind of big thing because it's
very very halloweeny it's the whole
thing is set on halloween everyone's in
costumes and it's just a lot of the
costumes look great oh i will give a
shout out too to that to whatever that
band is that's at the party that all the
adults at or at the town hall i really
love that the main singer guy's outfit
it's kind of it kind of looks like a
voodoo
type type of thing like it's kind of
like a top hat and he's all cobwebby and
he has like the skeleton makeup on but
it's yeah it's really really cool
looking but yeah so i mean the witches
look great bette midler is great like i
said she seems like she's just having a
[ __ ] blast the musical number's great
it's just like i like all the i like all
the stupid humor like especially her
like kind of making fun of the dumb
sisters
like knocking around and stuff i don't
know it just like cracks me up it
wouldn't always because like i said some
sometimes i'd be like yeah this is a
little too much for me right now like
all the screeching it's like give me a
headache but i don't know yesterday i
was just kind of like into it because
i'm like oh it's the day before
halloween and i'm watching it and it was
like super fun look at all the kids and
the trick or treated it was like super
fun but yeah so
this is actually i think it's on disney
plus but you can get it other places too
i think i actually rented it on google
play of all places but i think it's on
voodoo it's on some other places as well
so let me know how like where you come
down on the whole hocus pocus issue
because as i said i didn't realize i
might have seen it in the theater when
it came out and i was just like ah that
was fun you know it was fun halloween
movie even though it's [ __ ] july
whatever but it's it's interesting how
such a cult has grown up around it and i
guess i can see like i said i can see
why but i i can understand like some
people that are just kind of like i
don't get it um i don't get why so many
people love this movie so much but you
know this you know different opinions
whatever it's but i i'm really curious
to know how you guys is
uh where you guys fall on either side of
it like i said i'm not i'm kind of in
the middle you know when i'm in the mood
for it around halloween you know it
seems like totally fun but i can see i
can see people like not liking it too
because
it's it's kind of one of those movies
you know what i mean
and uh i think i maybe would have liked
it better if they'd gone like more of a
horror route you like you can put comedy
in it but it did the comedy does seem
like a little young you know aimed
toward like a younger demographic so i
would have been interested to see
what they would have done with it if
they made it like scarier but i'm also i
probably will see because like i said
they're making a sequel to it and they
just started shooting it like a week ago
literally as i'm recording this so i'll
be interested to see how that comes out
i'm pretty sure that like they're
getting
most of the cast back i thought i mean
they all seemed like they were pretty
interested in doing it especially since
this huge cult has grown up around the
movie in the years since it's come out
but yeah let me know what you think
about it in the comments and have a
happy halloween everybody this will
conclude my eek week i'll try to do it
again next year i might do a whole month
next year although
man doing the week this year was kind of
like kicked my ass but i get that was
because we were moving and there was a
bunch of other [ __ ] going on too and i
had a bunch of other projects going so i
didn't have as much time but i don't
know we'll see how it goes next year
maybe i can expand it because i actually
have had uh fun doing these but yeah so
that'll do it for my halloween eek week
movie review of hocus pocus and i will
see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
you